including something that just as of
yesterday
the rams had todd gurley under contract
were in discussions about a trade
reportedly the falcons and the dolphins
were the most interested the rams cut
todd gurley to avoid having another 10
and a half million dollars become fully
guaranteed under his contract that he
signed less than two years ago and now
peter already he's agreed to terms with
the atlanta falcons
well i'll just say this mike i think one
of the weirdest things in our society
is and i heard it last night i don't
know i was uh
we watched a little tv but i also did a
little bit of work otherwise and so i
was paying attention to to twitter and
to a couple of talk shows and i was
and all these people were saying oh my
god
and and i'm
it was like poor todd gurley
so i went to the trustee over the
cap.com site jason fitzgerald does a
great job of curating salaries
using mike florio adam schefter ian
rappaport whoever else you know
uh and uses all their information and
curates all the salaries and does a
fantastic job and i wanted to see one
thing
career earnings
so that you know i want to find out
should i feel sorry
for todd gurley
mike todd gurley who i believe is 26
years old
has made 38 million dollars
so i'm sorry the violin shall not play
in the peter king residence for todd
gurley and i get it everybody said well
geez they're really you know the
salaries are just screwing over the
running backs and and all that stuff
they're not screwing over the running
backs they're paying the running backs
what they are worth
in the nfl today
and if todd gurley didn't have mike
whatever he had if he didn't have the
arthritic knee or what you know look i
don't know what todd gurley has
and if i were the falcons
i'd be really really careful quite
honestly before you actually docusign a
contract or however they do those things
now
with todd gurley
because i would want how do you not have
it's my thought
how do you not have your own
team physician your own orthopedist
how is it possible
that you actually sign them
without doing a very thorough physical
exam on todd gurley
that's my big question has it one of the
biggest issues over the last two years
in the nfl almost two years hasn't one
of the biggest issues been
you know what's wrong with todd gurley
you know why have they have the rams
gone from hardly ever playing them
and and playing them in a limited way
and running them some
i mean
he went from being the superstar running
back of the nfl to now it's almost like
he's david johnson and so i
i don't know mike that's a that's a
multi-faceted answer and i'd love to
hear your thoughts
yeah and let's unpack some of this
because i think one of the reasons that
this has been so weird and strange and
vague the rams have treated the
condition of todd gurley's knee like
it's some sort of a state secret and i
think one of the reasons why todd gurley
is extremely sensitive about any talk
regarding his knee he got mad about it
last year when reporters would bring it
up peter i just wrote a few stories
about it and he blocked me on twitter
for crying out loud i didn't even insult
him let me earn the block todd let me
say something nasty if you're going to
block me for crying out loud i didn't
say anything but he's been very
sensitive about it and here's the
reality you mentioned the career
earnings look he had three years in as
the 10th overall pick in the draft in
2015
the reigning nfl offensive player of the
year the rams could have played it out
like the chargers did with melvin gordon
finish the fourth year of your rookie
contract play out the option year of
your rookie deal and then become a free
agent the rams paid this guy after three
seasons he made
34.5 million guaranteed over two years
that's 17.25 million a year for a
running back no running back makes that
other than todd gurley that is
unbelievable
and then the way the contract was
structured
on the verge of having another 10 and a
half million become fully guaranteed the
rams cut the court that contract was
negotiated to force the rams to make a
decision so now todd gurley becomes a
free agent which every player wants make
me a free agent every year so i can go
out and get the highest possible payday
he's got 34.5 million that he made over
two years he's a free agent able to sign
with any team he has a deal with the
falcons the next morning he wins it's a
jackpot it's a brilliant move by him by
his agents and the rams screwed this up
because they just could have paid out
every dollar under his rookie deal five
years said see you later god bless
godspeed good luck like melvin gordon is
currently trying to do and finding a new
deal that way todd gurley won big time
because he'd have been a free agent
anyway he'd have signed with the falcons
anyway and he's got 34.5 million over
the last two years to show for it
do you know the money yet from the
falcons
i don't know it yet and i'll tell you
what here's another thing that makes the
deal great
for
the
the uh todd gurley and his agent
31.95 million of the money he's made the
last two years is not subject to offset
of any kind no offset it's only 2.55
million the first 2.55 million he makes
from the falcons will be subject to
offset language so look i think i don't
know i was spitballing earlier today
peter i think five six million is fair
for todd gurley at this point when you
consider he will have a limited role i
wonder how much he accepts the fact that
he's not a workhorse that it needs to be
a limited role and he needs to be paid
accordingly he's got to get to that
point where he accepts he's not the guy
that he was when he signed that contract
in 2018.
yeah i mean
when you know when tom brady signed with
the uh with the bucks
um
a friend of mine uh you know another
media guy wrote to me and he said i'll
tell you who the
who the buck should go get right now for
very cheap dion lewis
because dion lewis basically can be that
guy out of the backfield that tom brady
is going to need is his crutch you know
the pass catching back and probably get
him for cheap
and that reminds me of the fact that i
don't think you're signing todd gurley
to be
derrick henry you obviously you
shouldn't be you're signing todd gurley
to be
a complimentary piece
and a co-running back with somebody else
so
i think he'd be very fortunate mike to
get a six million to
to clear this year six million dollars
or maybe you know if if they give him
some sort of bonus and a lower salary
this year
they just need to be able to in 2021
if things blow up and it goes badly they
need to let him go and not have
say 9 million bucks dead cat money
yeah i agree with you completely and let
me tell you there's another reason why
this physical that will be
conducted by someone somewhere somehow
under these covet 19 procedures a
neutral doctor who may have never
conducted a physical examination of a
professional athlete in his or her life
if there is a failure of that
examination if that knee keeps todd
gurley from passing the physical
peter the next move by gurley on this
broader chessboard is to go back to the
rams and say hey
that 10 and a half million that would
have become fully guaranteed if i was on
the roster today it was injury
guaranteed i can't pass a physical right
you owe me another 10 and a half million
on top of the 34.5 million and that may
work out to 45 million all told for todd
gurley for two years of football if he
can't pass a physical and if he can't
play and you know if you're todd gurley
there's an argument to be made that
maybe you just walk away with your 45
million plus what you made your first
three years in the nfl and call it a
career
so there's two things that play here
mike the more i think about todd gurley
suppose that todd gurley is living in la
okay to me the best thing that he could
do
if he's living in l.a
is he goes and sees
dr neil latrosh
you know who uh did tom brady's knee
surgery in 2008
um he did um shoot who's the receiver
with the rams
um who's who's knee super cub
a year or so ago yeah yeah that's right
that's right cooper cub he did his
surgery
and he's obviously very well trusted by
nfl teams
if he's in la that's who should examine
his knee that's number one number two
he went to georgia if i'm not mistaken
he lives in georgia as a home in georgia
or something
and so
would not he
be eligible perhaps
to
get one of the falcons team orthopedists
not in the facility but somewhere in
atlanta to do the exam of his knee
that i i mean that is a little bit shaky
what if the guy what if what if todd
gurley has an apartment in atlanta
wouldn't he then
couldn't the neutral doctor be somebody
who uh the falcons at least if he
doesn't work for the falcons
that he would be very familiar with
i think you're absolutely right now the
way they wrote up the rules on monday it
can't be a physical performed at the
team facility and the team doctors can't
go to the player it has to be a neutral
local physician but you're right in that
community in atlanta
the
falcons doctors will know someone that
they trust to do that physical and they
can guide them on what they need to look
at and what they need to do and if
there's an mri or an x-ray or whatever
the falcons doctors can also take a look
at that before anything gets finalized
but that 10 and a half million that the
rams would owe todd gurley that his
injury guaranteed at the time he was
terminated you can't cut a guy if he's
not healthy enough to pass a physical so
if he fails the physical the argument
becomes and my guess is it would be
resolved in a grievance procedure that
the rams owe todd gurley another 10 and
a half million dollars on top of what
they've already paid him so look this
was a win for todd gurley shannon sharp
and i got into a back and forth last
night on twitter that hey what happened
to you know he signed a contract and
honor the contract the bottom line is
the contract was constructed to front
load a ton of money and put triggers in
there to force the rams to make early
decisions gurley got free agency and
34.5 million dollars for two years he
won
big time and the rams lost big time
peter and you look at the rams now my
god what have they done with some of the
contracts they've negotiated in recent
years jared goff got a check for 21
million yesterday he has a cap number of
36 million they're looking to trade
brandon cooks who they gave a contract
to sight unseen when they gave up a
first round pick two years ago these
chickens have come home to roost in a
big way for the rams and this team is
going to be very different than the team
that went to the super bowl less than
two years ago
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports